ladies gentlemen it's time for another
trailers revisited we've been enjoying
doing this we've been doing it only once
a week right now and people seem to
really be like in our segment now we did
Drive we did Iron Man 3 and we did black
panther and what we basically do is we
go like how accurate was this movie
represented does it spoil a lot and also
this is we're going kind of with an
older older trailer now so it's gonna be
interesting to visit a trailer from the
90s to be like wow trailers are put
together way different oh yeah we're
doing episode 1 The Phantom Menace a
movie I haven't seen in a few years I
tried watching it before force awakens I
just couldn't get through it honestly
that's not me trying to be cool guy the
internet who bags in the Protocol's I
just I can't even sit through them seen
it a few times
god I'm excited was to see this chair
when you're a kid for online marketing
it's like they're really doing it
yeah it looks like it's going back to
like a new hope that doesn't look good
it looked good when it first trailer
came out okay
and if people not pick up that Jar Jar
would be annoying you refer to the
prophecy of the one over in balance to
the force you believe it's this boy you
can see things before they happen you
can have here the force is unusually
[Music]
[Music]
very the boy is dangerous they all sense
it why can't you do is the path to the
dark side fear leads to anger anger
leads to hate
[Music]
[Music]
there's a lot of things so there's some
things we just got to kind of be like
forgiving on because they've really
updated the way they edit trailers now
well yeah I mean this feels like the
trailer for like a video like they're
presenting some special award at the
Oscars or something in their place yeah
cuz it's also like a medley of tones -
it starts out very slow and very like
tracking and you're you're intrigued
just pulling you in and then all of a
sudden it becomes like a really rapid
hits of like thrilling moments and then
they go down a certain scene yeah the
like we're gonna explain the main action
of the story to you yeah montages again
at the end I remember when I first saw
the effects when I was a kid at least I
didn't look at the effects going that
lose awful you know and I don't think
anyone did from the trailers I think
from the trailers this look like great
visual effects for its time and now when
you look back at it you're like oh yeah
it doesn't let hasn't aged well oh yeah
what I think is so interesting about
this trailer it doesn't cover a lot of
the ground that Phantom Menace really
delves into you know what are the things
that people hate about the Phantom
Menace besides the fact that it's like
really corny and been poorly it's super
political you've got a bunch of other
problems there's a lot of Jar Jar
because there's a ton with Queen Amidala
that they don't get up you for in them
but this trailer does is it makes you
think you're going in to watch a
personal story about the beginnings of a
young Darth Vader a young Anakin
Skywalker and all the all the scenes
they choose are all Anakin effort it's
like it's Anakin is the story of how
Anakin's gonna become you know Darth
Vader and now we had teachers yeah
squabbling over this how we met Obi one
and then also the Jedi Council being
like you know there's darkness and this
little kid man be careful of it it looks
like it's all Anakin based when that's
not the Phantom Menace in fact it might
have been better if they just contained
it and kept it mainly Anakin base and
maybe got a different actor than that
kid
[Music]
the things that we found most annoying
the performances Jar Jar and the kid are
barely featured in the trailer yeah yeah
and I mean you know Jar Jar shows up and
even has lines a couple of times but it
just doesn't look like he's gonna be
like your sidekick yeah it doesn't look
like a big presence when there's they go
to like whatever that Jar Jar world is
called they're gonna like charge our
world in underwater they widen that big
or at the end where Anakin does the
blowing up the thing and as a pilot but
it's not really just the contain Anakin
story that's what we all went in to see
but you got like this a much bigger
thing that will also ended up being more
boring and disappointing ultimately
because the marketing around it was all
I remember that it's like cool ass
Anakin Skywalker poster where it's young
little Anakin and as a shadow oh yeah
yeah I think that's what you're going in
for that's our you're gonna get I mean
eventually I guess you can argue by
episode three it all ties it in yeah
it's part of it but yeah I don't know
that that movie could have been written
and organized in a different fashion
there are some cool things you know I
mean I wish in hindsight
I mean it's cool that they showed just
that one like Darth Maul lighting of the
double sided saber yeah you know like
you see him here and there in a couple
of shots because I was like his main
featured shot I remember that got us
excited and that was one of the few
things oh everyone wanted Darth Maul
shirt even before toy before it even saw
the movie yeah I feel like that's one
thing about that movie that's aged
pretty well like people still think
that's cool you know yeah Darth Maul's
legit
the force awakens does a similar thing
where their trailers open up on like
sand planets like reminding you have
going back to like a new home when Luke
was on Tatooine yeah that's what this
does here too is like oh we're cool
what's crazy about this trailer is one
of the things that gets criticized the
most about this movies is overblown use
of CGI and you don't really get the
sense of overblown uses CGI in this
trailer yeah it looks like a contained
movie yeah yeah it looks like a
contained movies one sort of focus and
it pitches everything like it's
relatively thrilling and there are parts
of that movie that just sort of stop
with that the first part of this trailer
really pulled me and I was like okay
maybe this is gonna be one of those like
really
trailers but like this trailer kind of
like the movie is very uneven in his
pace and how it's you know yeah hanging
out it story well I think back then that
was a great trailer because you got to
keep in mind too true there wasn't like
online marketing and all that back then
this was the first thing you saw in the
theaters this was this wasn't on YouTube
or whatever yeah and you couldn't go
back and pick it apart exactly you would
just go to the theaters so you could try
to catch some footage of the new Star
Wars movie that we've been waiting
decades for seeing those things were
like let's like cut like a special fan
made trailer so that was cool that I
mean now it's like as a kind of crap
trailer but at the time yeah that made
it feel really special and really
thrilling
I think the trailer was better than the
movie yeah yeah this made me kind of
soft trailer because yeah interesting
hey you got any recommendations for what
we could do for trailers revisited
primarily just go off.that for this one
leave some requests down below guys you
can subscribe to the reel rejects click
that notification bell to get notified
every time one of our videos is up check
us out on patreon full-length music
video and TV show reactions including
Runaways a Riverdale attack on titan my
hero academia the flash black lightning
and more to come Wayne's ball on patreon
check us out